hier soir sur m6 elle un nouvel épisode
de top chef et pour l'occasion
l'émission pouvait compter sur la
présence de big flo et oli
je sais que kelly adore big flo et oli
elle est d'ailleurs si vous leur faire
un petit bisou ils sont là ils doivent
nous regarder combien d'amour merci vous
a tout résumé
regardez hier soir sur m6 les
téléspectateurs de top chef ont pu
apercevoir les rappeurs big flo et oli
sur leur écran
mais pas question pour eux d'interpréter
un titre de leur album la vie de rêve
en revanche les deux toulousains étaient
invités pour jouer les critiques
culinaires un rôle qu'ils ont pris très
au sérieux dès le début c'est ambitieux
prendre la confiance
après big flo c'est au tour de lit de se
glisser lui aussi dans son rôle de juge
et il n'a pas hésité à dénoncer quitte à
se faire quelques ennemis
moi si je peux me permettre un truc
d'ailleurs je trouve ça super bon je ne
retrouve pas tous les saveurs du
cassoulet quoi danser version revisitée
du cassoulet l'une des spécialités de
toulouse certains plans et étonné par
leur apparence
ça m'interpelle va soit là pour le coup
si on emmène sa sans mot dire ce que
c'est je n'ai aucune info que c'est un
garçon lester l'impression que c'est un
falafel mais au delà de la critique big
flo et oli ont aussi aidé les vrais
juges de l'émission adoucir leur verdict
n'hésitons pas à utiliser l'humour pour
détendre l'atmosphère
monsieur se prend pour qui se prend le
rappeur un passage remarqué qui a attiré
plus de deux millions six cent mille
téléspectateurs sur m6
[Applaudissements]
les questions que je fais des grands
pics laurie les chéri e m6 a perdu 3 142
mille téléspectateurs d'une semaine
c'est ça une troisième de la soirée mais
quand même un bon 25% sur un manager
agir topchef ça reste quand même un
programme très très fort regardez hier
c'est france 2 qui est arrivé en tête
des audiences hier soir à 21h
disparition inquiétante et leur nouvelle
fiction car cartonné sur près de 1 5
million de téléspectateurs
esprits criminels ça va plus du tout sur
tf1 esprits criminels mais j'adore en
plus c'est simplement moi j'adore
j'adore les essais privés
voilà quoi c'est ça ça marche plus non
il va adorer les criminels n'ont pas dû
toucher dans les esprits oui parce qu'un
inédit et des rediffs à la peine en
prenant deux points d'un script il
prenait top chef numéro 3 la carte aux
trésors avec notre ami cyril féraud il
est re div deux copines paradis sont
arrivés en tête sur la télé oui avec 784
mille téléspectateurs